And are they constantly looking for new animators? Always. Always, right. Yeah.
Yeah. I, I guess it's cause if you're not getting paid like a lot,
it's hard to find.
So yeah. Uh, actually if you too expensive,
so all day we don't have to Birgit stories over some one else. Right?
You mentioned Twitter as well as I hardly find a lot of the newer talent.
Future also, because now we're on Twitter. I think, you know, the generation,
some quite a friend, an amazing animators who, yeah,
welcome pretty much, pretty much. I'm just wondering. So.
Is there this much of a shortage of animators in Japan that they have to look
literally on Twitter,
they're doing what we do and just browsing Twitter and being like you, you,
you seem to have a good time.
All by your recommendation by, uh, by your, as a senpai. Oh,
I had walk with this young guy he's pretty skilled for, or,
um, I will have walked with this. We had some program,
but you can manage to walk on it. Uh, so you have, uh, depends.
I see if you walk with a friend, people, you,
you know that they are learning by themselves by themselves and they're doing
all the best as they want and they accepted the amount of money. And so,
uh, they, they actually accident.
It's no more because they are learning by yourself and yeah.
You have to teach them how to get better.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Because I actually have like an artist friend who used to like draw stuff for me
years ago, he ended up being an animator for a black Clover. Yeah. Same here.
Like I had a, like a,
an artist who I was following in an animator and then they just showed up,
working on solo art online. Yeah. Shout out to Kate,
shout out to Kay animations. It's just weird. How that, like,
I didn't think like, I'd always heard of like the web gen animators,
we call them, but like, I've never actually like seen it happen.
So when I saw it happen, I was like, Oh wow.
They actually use Twitter as like a formal thing. Like yeah, exactly.
Sings. Uh, the flashpoint we can take, like was maybe at
the border too. It is at the 65 or you have a, Oh,
that fight.
That's the moment she Saskia versus Saskia narrative versus MoMA. Shiki guides.
Yeah.
And in fact, a is the director was, uh, uh, cyclical son. And, uh,
he he's a Chinese guy who success to, um,
Oh, call a lot of foreign animators.
And he was by himself for doing the assistant projects in, by himself, uh,
trying to contact a lot of animators,
check her darker to put some correction.
And I think he had spent, uh, two months study,
but because of him, he could manage a lot of animators to walk on disappeared.
And the piece of 65 of Bartow was a masterclass.
Yeah. I mean, that was my favorite flights. I've seen the fight.
I don't know anything, but I know I haven't seen, I haven't seen burrito.
I've just seen that fight. And that was my fault,
like the best flights of the year.
Right. And with these explicit is proof. Okay.
For an animators can also walk Japanese animation,
but you have problems about communication.
You have some staff who have to speak
English or if they can speak Japanese it's okay.
Or sometimes you have some mistakes by them, but yes, it's a,
if you work with foreign, some it's happened better. Uh,
if you correct them and we do the best to.
What would you say is the best way for,
let's say a young animator to get involved in the anime industry now?
Well, no, like I said, it depends the experience you want. If you want,
just walk out, just want to walk on one piece. We would just want, okay.
So Twitter will be okay. I think, uh,
or I won't just a one year experience. Uh, I, so I, okay. Let's see.
If you want to come to Japan,
you have to find us to Duke could prove you a visa.
Couldn't be a lot of hoops to jump. And if you want a carrier,
I want to work in Japan. I want to live in Japan.
I want to marry the Japanese girl.
I want that ideal Wiebe lives. So.
For you to assume,
we're going to have enough time and money to marry a Japanese girls and
animator. I was thinking of asking, but I don't know how postal is.
Cause you mentioned that like obviously the San pies,
they have a family and whatnot. How the does anyone date?
Because it sounds like you guys never leave the office. How do you,
do you bring them to the office? You're like, hold on. I'm gonna do a key frame.
I'll answer the question.
Have you ever brought a date to the office.
That, um, actually, yes. So, uh, I'm working at this to do and, and also, um,
so sometime I'm working on two shows at the same time.
So I'm working on the movie and sometimes.
Again, how did you find the time
unless you're dating another key animator, she's two lock style
tables away.
I prefer not data to,
[inaudible] speaking a bit about animations for going to a bit cure my passion.
I will say I prefer to talk as a scenes. Uh.
Oh yeah, of course. I mean,
you have the love of your life revolving around making a show where you want to
break.
I'm thinking any mission. I, I walk on emission I and emissions.